it all came down to this a handwritten
sheath of notes with which Jose Ruben
Zamora made a last-ditch attempt to
prove his innocence
after a trial which both he and
international rights organizations have
denounced as a politicized persecution
this was the verdict
Jose Ruben Zamora is found guilty of
money laundering for this infraction the
sentence is six years of prison
the 66 year old is the founder of el
periodical a leading newspaper in
Guatemala that regularly investigated
authorities including the president and
attorney general
but no more last July he was accused of
money laundering and blackmail in a
trial which he and his supporters say
hasn't resembled anything like justice
from the start
all of my rights were violated we
weren't given access to the case File we
were kept 10 days in solitary
confinement without sleeping subjected
to psychological pressure
things only got worse
I have had nine defense lawyers
the majority were persecuted by the
Guatemalan state four ended up in prison
two left the country before heading off
to serve his term he was asked if he had
a message for the president Alejandro
gemate I am still innocent and he is
still a thief and nobody is going to
take that away
dozens of Judges prosecutors and
journalists have been forced to flee the
country or wound up in prison say civil
rights organizations
it's a backlash orchestrated by
Guatemala's minority Elite after a U.N
backed anti-corruption commission put
them under the spotlight before being
kicked out of the country in 2019 says
Claudia Ordonez from article 19.
now comes the revenge against operators
of justice and journalists who had a
moment of freedom and calm to do
critical work and we're seeing that now
against rights Defenders and journalists
we have 20 people registered as having
fled
now Guatemala is coming up to elections
in under two weeks time with another
voice silenced and more questions than
ever about its wobbling democracy John
Holman Al Jazeera